We have a voicemail number, which is two one
nine two David P..
This is an interesting observation about some
of these recent interviews that Donald Trump
has been doing.
Take a listen.
Hey, David.
As I was listening to the Fox and Friends
interview sources or coverage of that, I realized
that Trump has gotten so bad at inner demons,
so bad at even the propaganda.
Yes.
They literally have to give him the answer
or he answers that question.
You replay that, Brian, kill me.
He asked the question.
Gibson the answer.
And then waits for Trump to just say yes.
Basically, that's what we're going to do.
And he still finds a way to invest it all.
Yes, I have noticed this.
It friendly interviewers will.
It's sort of like priming a five year old
to give you the answer that that you know
how like when you talked to little kids just
by how you talk to them, you can basically
get them to go along with a lot of different
things.
And you say, hey, little Donny, do you like
it?
Is the apple or the cherry bigger?
Right.
Which which one looks bigger?
Does that apple look bigger?
Yes.
Yes, the apple looks bigger.
You're priming answers and friendly interviewers
will do this to Trump and they'll do it when
they ask him these seemingly simple questions
like what is your agenda?
Or something about the via the.
Give him the answers.
And Trump could say, you're absolutely right.
That's exactly right.
And I'm glad that we're all on the same page.
Trump still gets the answers wrong when some
somebody gives him the answers and a.
That's an astute observation from our caller
on the bonus show today.
Los Angeles is saying they will shut off water
and electricity to homes, hosting large parties
and gatherings in the context of corona virus.
Can they do it?
What will happen?
We will discuss.
Also, New York City, as we are starting to
see a resurgence in cases in a lot of different
states, New York City is setting up quarantine
checkpoints for travelers who are coming in
from coronavirus hotspots.
Massachusetts is thinking about similar strategies.
What is the fall going to look like?
And lastly, on top of everything, we've gotten
an updated 20/20 hurricane forecast and it
looks very bad.
And we already saw in Florida what happens
when you combine a relatively small hurricane
slash tropical storm with a corona virus outbreak?
We are going to discuss what happens when
it is a major hurricane combined with a coronavirus
hotspot.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show.
I'll see you then or tomorrow.